School teachers right now is convergent
thinking and so that means that there's
multiple variables and one correct
answer and so it's like one plus one
equals two there's only one answer and
now they're even telling you there's
only one way to find the answer and if
you don't find it the way they want you
to find it then it's also wrong which is
ridiculous but anyways my Virgin
thinking is when you have multiple
variables but multiple correct answers
how many different ways can you use a
brick what's interesting about that is
that you can also have multiple right
answers and some answers that are more
right than others which becomes very
difficult to grade but also how the real
world works and we're rewarded based on
how right our YouTube video really is
right or how right our article is or how
right our product is and how we can
solve problems using more creative
methods than trying to converge on a
single answer because if it's a
convergent thinking process for the most
part it's already been kind of automated
and everyone can do it more of the
education systems be around Divergent
thinking and diversion problem solving